it's exciting to be here both of us and
you know this is lee had a great vision
years ago when he first came here about
CAA about what it could mean Susan Fagan
grabbed it and ran with it Susan Fagan
has been the phenomenal leader in the
development of columbia alumni
association and just one person i want
to recognize its in the audience today
that I always consider the founder of
CAA and she doesn't mind just standing
up and saying hello Donna Rosenthal
Donna
ghana's heart hard work and spirit made
this organization come together when you
go back and think about how successful
it is today and there were a lot of
skeptics in those early days different
vertical groups in in various schools
that wanted to keep their own and try to
combine this and put everything together
so that we could do it not just in the
United States and and but throughout the
world and it's been terrific so we have
a great opportunity today to put Lee
Bollinger under the spotlight and ask
them a few questions so I've got a bunch
of questions I'm going to start with so
we can tell you about where we are
there's so many things in the in the
roughly ten years almost ten years that
he's been the president university is I
think all of you who have been around
here a long time recognize the enormity
of change there's nothing that Lee looks
at but he doesn't feel that he could
make better and and we all benefit from
that he drives us all to to greater
heights and I think some of the things
that you'll hear from him today will
give you some idea about our important
he thinks and believes in the future of
the University so the first thing we did
is trustees not being completely stupid
but you never know we we signed Lee up
to another contract a year ago so he is
now in the second year of a new
five-year contract going into his tenth
year what's that feel like Dean no look
it's a dud it's too late to change your
mind so that's a question we want to
know how you feel yeah I can tell them
how you yeah yeah yeah yeah so so I
think we all feel just like I do that
that there's a fantastic time for the
University it's when you look at how
much we have to work with fantastic
students and gifted very distinguished
faculty a wonderful administration great
trustees led by Bill we have space for
the first time in a hundred years I mean
literally we have the space to do what
people at Columbia did at the beginning
of the last century and that was a time
when Columbia was graded as we know it
today and now that is the place in which
we can create Columbia for the century
the resources are still challenged
compared to our peers in terms of the
endowment but the performance on the
endowment is better than any other
university in the United States for the
past five or six years the giving
so giving this is great love okay it's
under night yeah I'm gonna pepper you
with a bunch of questions right you're
very I want to make sure it's over you
know I you initiated a strategic
analysis of where this university was in
it in the among its peers called on some
outside people to do some evaluation of
where we were from that you develop the
plan and you develop the long-term plan
that said we were going to get the
University back in the top five there
are very few groups out there that
evaluate the performance of universities
but the one that makes a lot of sense to
everybody is US News this is our second
year of being in the top five we're
number for reaction so the whenever the
US News and World Report ranks you lo
you don't pay any attention to it and
when it ranks you well you see you
really say how great it is it's
extremely important to the institution
to be ranked fourth in the United States
by US News and World Report I think all
of us also realize that Colombia is
among that handful of truly truly great
university both the history the present
and the future so i would say bill that
that you know we have shared a view that
the only reason for doing these jobs is
to try to make this institution the very
tough in the in the world and that's a
kind of commitment that's both fun which
is why i think people are here because a
great institution to work with and we
are making progress on them I think
that's just a sign of it so so there
were a lot of components of this this
number for ranking for us and you know
you mentioned one just briefly take us a
little deeper into the performance of
the endowment and what you did when you
came here you know underperforming
and you put the right people in place to
make things happen so we had two big
problems at Columbia that that really
helped or could block our potential one
was space and we'll come back to space
and talk about what we've done and the
other was resources so sometime middle
of the 20th century the endowments of
Harvard and Columbia were identical and
as we know our Birds endowment today is
over 30 billion in our endowment is now
close to eight billion that's very
important in terms of the resources of
the institution we have to try to make
up the difference because we want to be
the best university in the world well to
do that we have to have connected alumni
and we have to have people who feel part
of this that's why we wanted to have a
university-wide alumni associate that's
why you're here that's why Donna was
there at the beginning when we raised
this and that's why this is working we
created a four billion dollar capital
campaign the largest in colombia's
history by far and then finished that
goal a year early despite the great
recession raised the goal extended at
the five billion that's the largest
campaign goal of any university of the
united states the endowment
that it counts pledges if you just take
actual dollars in every single year we
were 13th or 14th in the country eight
nine years ago we're now regularly three
or four were always top five in the
actual giving every year those are very
significant facts and then of course we
count on our professionals to take that
money and to manage it very very
effectively in this past year the
endowment returned twenty-three point
six percent you know that is a tribute
to nard Narvekar and his team has
nothing to do with bill as it has or
George it has nothing special George and
it has nothing nothing to do with me at
all it is a fantastic performance and in
fact over the past I think it's six
seven years it is as I said the highest
performing endowment of any endowment
over a billion dollars University
Foundation or otherwise in the United
States so you should know that the
resources that are contributed that a
raise that you help us raise our manage
exceptionally well last thing I'd say is
that 8 million versus 30 there's eight
billion versus 30 billion is still very
real but you have to remember that we
live in New York City and New York City
is so attractive that that's worth about
15 to 20 billion dollars in an endowment
so actually our endowments about 20 25
billion and we're very close to
Harvard's 30 billion we like we like
Lee's math you know you mentioned you
mentioned the campaign and and I think
rightly so you know the effort that
you've made to it in that five-year plan
that we had there were a lot of people
during very difficult times cutback
development staff and you saw in fact
just the opposite you and Susan and Fred
van sickle went after it hired more
people put them out throughout the world
and the results have been just fantastic
i really have
really have it is it's a real tribute to
leave that he saw the opportunity we've
had development alumni relations
organization as part of the trustees and
Richard Witten is here today is that is
the chair of that committee he worked so
closely with Susan and and Fred all
during that time but you know to see us
in the top two or three on annual and
the be as resourceful as we've been with
our capital campaign the fact is we
extended it from four billion 25 billion
is Lee indicated and it's still going
very strong we had a report on that
yesterday with the trustees